- À Old Orchard, un début de
saison estivale qui a des airs
de retour à la normale.
PAUL CARNEY, propriétaire, Old
Orchard Beach Airbrush
"Pour les affaires, le pire
est derrière nous", assure
ce commerçant. Mais il déplore
l'absence prolongée de bons
clients. Les touristes
canadiens, surtout les
québécois, qui en temps normal,
sont nombreux à choisir le Maine
comme destination de vacances.
- Casquette, merci beaucoup!
- Des mots qu'il n'a pas eu
l'occasion de pratiquer depuis
la fermeture de la frontière
entre le Canada et
les États-Unis, en mars 2020.
- On s'ennuie
- À ce motel, les Québécois
représentent, en temps normal,
de 40 à 60 % de la clientèle.
Un vide que les touristes
américains ne comblent pas.
SARAH ALEXANDER
gérante, Motel Beau Rivage
- Les Québécois prennent 3 ou 5
jours, peut-être une semaine.
C'est différent, c'est un gros
changement pour nous aussi
d'avoir une petite vacance d'un
ou deux jours des Américains qui
viennent de proche.
- Elle suit avec attention
l'évolution des discussions
autour de la frontière
Canado-Américaine
dont la fermeture la prive
de nombreuses réservations.
- Si on ouvre pas les douanes
cet été, ça va faire deux ans,
c'est quand même...
c'est beaucoup.
- Cette impatience exprimée par
des acteurs du secteur
touristique est partagée
par des élus. Des démocrates et
des républicains du Maine sur la
côte est, à l'État de Washington
sur la côte ouest, en passant
par New-York et
le New Hampshire.
- Sept États de la Nouvelle-
Angleterre, comme le Maine et le
Vermont voisins, a l'un des taux
de vaccination les plus élevés
au pays. Plus de la moitié
de la population a reçu
ses deux doses.
Un argument en faveur d'une
réouverture sécuritaire des
voyages non essentiels à la
frontière, selon le gouverneur
de l'État.
CHRIS SUNUNU, gouverneur
républicain, New Hampshire
"C'est important pour
l'économie, les familles et les
loisirs", dit l'élu, qui propose
même de partager des doses
excédentaires avec le Canada.
Mais comment vérifier
si un voyageur transfrontalier
est vraiment vacciné?
Le gouverneur républicain, qui
s'oppose lui-même à l'idée d'un
passeport vaccinal, croit que la
réouverture de la frontière ne
peut pas attendre l'issue d'un
tel débat, politiquement
sensible aux États-Unis.
Chose certaine, les pressions
des élus d'États frontaliers
se font ressentir
jusqu'à Washington.
MARYSCOTT GREENWOOD, DG, Conseil
des affaires canado-américaines
- De quoi influencer la prise de
décision au Congrès, mais aussi
sein de la Maison-Blanche
de Joe Biden. Selon elle,
le vent est donc en train de
tourner aux États-Unis en faveur
de la relance des activités
à la frontière.
Pays, États et provinces sont
toujours en pourparlers.
Des tractations qui
détermineront quand les
voyageurs canadiens déferleront
de nouveau sur les côtes
du Maine.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair
Radio-Canada,Ol